quanti di voi hanno un cane un gatto a
casa tanti allora sappiate che avete un
vantaggio evolutivo da questo punto di
vista
quelli che vedete sono soltanto alcuni
ritagli di giornali ma veramente pochi
che dicono come avere un animale a casa
ci renda le persone più intelligenti
anche i bambini più intelligenti
rinforza il sistema immunitario
soffrendo meno di allergie
abbiamo meno probabilità di contrarre
infatti addirittura ma perché succede
questo cioè perché nel momento in cui tu
accarezzi un cane si abbassa la
pressione sanguigna liberi endorfine via
dicendo
la motivazione principale che il bisogno
di relazionarci agli animali è innestato
nel nostro dna ci siamo poi voluti con
loro
cioè non esiste un umanità senza le
altre specie animali e questo vale per
tutte le culture anche quelle più povere
questa è una fotografia di una fase che
si chiama mattern aggio che è stato
quello che per esempio ha reso possibile
la domesticazione del lupo che poi è
diventato cane
noi pensiamo agli animali ci
confrontiamo con loro ogni volta che
dobbiamo creare immaginare ogni volta
che dobbiamo anche soltanto costruire la
nostra identità di esseri umani spesso
il concetto di animalità era tutto ciò
che non è umano oggi la si pensa un
pochino diversamente anche l'essere
umano ha una propria animalità ecco val
la pena però di considerare questo non è
sufficiente avere un cane in giardino
così per avere dei benefici o se non
altro questi benefici possono essere
massimizzati ma come rendendoci conto
che in ognuna di queste piccole testo
grandi teste anche se parliamo per
esempio degli elefanti
esiste un mondo una soggettività un
particolare modo di percepire il mondo
una vita emotiva e già darwin nel 1800
scriveva l'espressione delle emozioni
nell'animale nell'uomo comparandole tra
di loro
ecco quello che stiamo per vedere un
filmato di un gorilla che si chiama
cocco è una femmina di gorilla cui è
stato insegnato il linguaggio dei segni
quindi cocco può raccontare come si
senta interessante questo quindi
di cocco sarà alle prese con un film che
il suo film preferito
c'è una parte molto particolare però in
questo film in cui c'è un commiato tra
un bambino e la propria mamma
le persone a cui questo bambino è
affezionato e coco vive talmente
intensamente questa cosa talmente tanto
si dispiace che gira le spalle smette di
schiena espressione
per coerenza e coraggio
non appena si comincia a gesticolare
poi difficile
è una piccola incursione nella mente di
un animale e pensate quando questi
animali noi di prendiamoli rendiamo
schiavi mettiamo in uno zoo e poi
andiamo lì mangiandoci le noccioline
che tipo di realtà loro devono vivere no
allora è interessante la frase di konrad
lorenz che dice chiunque conosca
intimamente un mammifero superiore come
un cane una scimmia non si convince che
tale essere sentimenti simili ai suoi e
psichicamente anormale ed è questo
renderci conto che ci rende esseri umani
migliori ma non migliori gandhi già
diceva il progresso morale di una
nazione da si può misurare in base a
come tratta gli animali no il fatto che
noi se noi riconosciamo nell'animale una
mente pensante allora sorgono degli
interrogativi possiamo confrontarci
possiamo capire che cosa sta succedendo
lì dentro
e poi un'altra bella cosa e che
l'animale soprattutto i nostri cani a
casa ti accettano un po così come sei
sono maestri di accettazione
incondizionata che tu sia alto basso
enrico povera loro ne frega nulla però
sono molto distanti da noi sono più
distanti di altri esseri umani ed ecco
che diventa questa relazione una
palestra per esercitare empatia con
passione comunicazione non verbale via
dicendo
c'è stata un uno psicologo che ha
neuroscienziato per la precisione ha
studiato il modo in cui cani ci amano li
ha sottoposti ad una tomografia ad
emissione di positroni mentre il cane
era era in restano gli ho insegnato
questa cosa però c'è stato un consenso
per i cani potevano andarsene quando
volevano è un consenso per il
proprietario che hanno dovuto firmare no
perché dovevano essere trattati anche
bene
ebbene lui ha scoperto non soltanto che
gli animali ci amano ma anche il modo
particolare in cui lo fanno
e la cosa straordinaria che poi abbia
scritto un articolo apparso sul new york
times dal titolo anche i cani sono
persone perché persone perché noi
utilizziamo come sinonimo umano uguale
persona no persona significa deriva da
maschera carattere quello che
caratterizza un individuo e quanti di
noi che hanno il proprio cane a casa
anche due cani della stessa cucciolata
ognuno la propria personalità diciamo
questo renderci conto che magnifica
questa relazione c'è stato ci sono state
anche delle sentenze giuridiche ed india
hanno decretato che i delfini sono
persone non umane la corte dei giudici
di buenos aires ha decretato che un
orango ton che viveva nello zoo di
buenos aires fosse una persona non umana
ne ha ordinato l'immediata scarcerazione
quindi poi se ne sono occupate in un
santuario in brasile quindi anche
giuridicamente cioè un seguito da questo
punto di vista ed è nato un movimento
che si chiama mining animals ma non
soltanto mente ma anche presta
attenzione non mind step occhi al
gradino
ecco mining nemo significa quindi
riconoscere che gli animali abbiano una
mente e trattarli con attenzione
trattati con cura e stato uno psicologo
che si chiama paul ekman che ha studiato
l'espressione delle emozioni degli
esseri umani e ha visto che in tutto il
mondo
gioia tristezza paura sorpresa disgusto
vengono espresse nello stesso modo
e bene hanno fatto lo stesso studio nei
cani e del risultato che anche loro si
tutti quanti hanno delle espressioni
comune e il nostro
diciamo che le nostre capacità impatti
che vengono sviluppate nel momento in
cui ci esercitiamo a guardare queste
espressioni
in modo che quando siamo di fronte ad un
animale possiamo renderci conto come in
questo caso per esempio che c'è disagio
una lieve paura oppure euforia o al
contrario quando ci relazioniamo con
animali selvatici non sono soltanto beni
da vedere ma possiamo riconoscere
protezione cura amore
esattamente come ci dicono gli etologi
cognitivi queste sono macachi che fanno
il bagno in acque termali in giappone
sono delle pozze termali libere
soprattutto per loro sono diventate
un'icona è riusciti a vederla questa
espressione di completo relax e
abbandono sul loro volto giusto come
anche qui possiamo vedere l'espressione
di curiosità e attenzione a questa è la
faccia di un animale vivo che fa
esattamente la vita che dovrebbe fare è
molto molto molto diverso rispetto a
quando ci sono situazioni come questa
non brutte soltanto perché sono in
gabbia e che noi su questi volti
possiamo riconoscere disperazione
rassegnazione questa testa inclinata di
lato della bocca aperta e gli occhi
bassi dire ho urlato urlato tutto il
tempo ma nessuno aperto questa caspita
di gabbia e attenzione
la maggior parte degli animali che sul
nostro pianeta interagiscono con di
esseri umani vivono in questo modo
perché noi abbiamo una convinzione è
fatto tutto per noi non rendendoci conto
che invece siamo in un unico sistema
siamo interdipendenti
non siamo in un sistema isolato noi
siamo al centro
siamo parte della rete della vita questo
è un fatto terribile no di un animale
che viene schiavizzato cioè in seguito
molti animali per molti animali succede
questo
ed è parte di una campagna di peta
quanto diversa invece guardare gli
animali nel loro habitat o che fanno la
vita che devono e sull'espressione del
piccolo voi potete guardare che c'è
curiosità giocosità e nell'espressione
della mamma un sacco di pazienza
lo dice ma angelo possibile anche negli
occhi di un ippopotamo io posso vedere
queste cose ma se non si curano anche
l'espressione sempre quella beh vi dico
quando una nippo pota ma è arrabbiato ve
ne accorgete subito senza ombra di
dubbio
val la pena quindi e per questo gli
animali soprattutto quelli nelle nostre
case
diventano cioè ci lanciano la
possibilità di esercitarsi non nello
sviluppare empatia perché ad ogni nostra
azione gesticolazione tono di voce
espressione del voto stringere le
distanze allontanarci guardare una parte
dall'altra loro cambiano la loro
espressione anche di poco ed essere ed è
essere attente le sottigliezze che ci
rende ancora più bravi empaticamente per
esempio queste sono le foto 2 foto del
mio cane sembrano identiche ma ci sono
delle differenze nella foto di destra
vita delle orecchie più larghe per
esempio avete una testa che si scosta di
lato e una testa lievemente più bassa e
questo è un significato ma la prima cosa
che dobbiamo fare accorge cioè di questa
cosa
pertanto attribuirgli subito il
significato vivendo con loro che si
imparano un po le cose
ecco che così possiamo andare ancora più
a fondo e riconoscere tenerezza tratto
gli animali sono genitori favolosi non
distratti dagli smartphone riusciti a
vedere attraverso queste cose quindi non
è un impressione è che uno vede una foto
come questa dice ma sembra quasi che sia
amore ma no è proprio cosi sono capace
di questi sentimenti gli animali così
come anche possiamo vedere l'intensità
di questo sguardo tra un genitore il
piccolo ho una bambina di 9 anni e ho
visto tanti genitori mai compreso a
volte che non aveva la stessa senza
degli animali sono genitori favolosi
possiamo imparare tanto da loro
qui c'è un sacco di presenza non sono
distratto con altro e tra l'altro questa
pero se presenza e personalizzata lo
stato in cui ti trovi in questo momento
non soltanto a te come individuo
presenza cioè essere di non mentre il
tuo figlio ti parlo ci fai qualcosa te
stai pensando già da
altre cose è uno dei mali del nostro
tempo quello che alza lo stress così
tanto così come anche voi occuparti di
altro ma sto attento a quello che fa e
supervisione oppure questo ancora più
interessante avete un cucciolo che viene
redarguito e ammonito questa cosa non
devi farla lo vedete nonché contrariato
il cucciolo
guardate l'espressione dell'adulto cieli
sta dicendo non è in dubbio l'amore che
provo per te non sei in dubbio tu in
quanto individuo è in dubbio soltanto il
tuo comportamento e quante volte noi ce
ne dimentichiamo
se non fai come ti dico ti privo del mio
amore
ecco che gli animali diventano maestri
anche di amore incondizionato non
dipende da quello che fai quanto io bene
ti voglio posso darti una guida possa
educarte da questo punto di vista ma non
è in dubbio quello che io provo per te
questo crea esseri umani sani oltre che
animali sani
ora quello che secondo me noi dovremmo
notare a questo punto è questo la mente
degli animali quella che procura tutte
queste emozioni cognizioni aspettative
piani curiosità creatività addirittura
per molti animali è un insieme di
piccoli punti che noi chiamiamo neuroni
che tra di loro inter connettendosi
diventano un cervello diventano una
mente ma la stessa cosa funziona anche
tra individui o meglio tra organi del
corpo per esempio poi hai un individuo
ma tra individui succede una cosa cioè
diventa un'entità diversa cioè le
proprietà di una cellula sono diverse da
quelle di un tessuto di un cervello e le
proprietà di una società o di un gruppo
sociale sono diverse da quelle del
singolo individuo ma c'è ancora di più
da fare da questo punto di vista nel
senso diversi etologi cognitivi diverse
teologi anche oggi dicono alla base
dell'evoluzione e possibile che non ci
sia stata la competizione ma la
cooperazione anche tra specie differenti
questo è quello che noi dovremmo
ricordarci non più metterci
al di sopra degli altri animali pensando
di essere l'essere umano è più
intelligente oggi separa di intelligenze
anche all'interno degli esseri umani
stesso soltanto della specie umana
voglio dire einstein diceva ognuno è un
genio ma se giudichi un pesce dalla sua
capacità di salire sugli alberi penserà
di essere uno stupido per tutta la vita
non possiamo prendere la nostra scala
umana attribuire agli altri animali di
questo qua sono sono stupidi perché ce
lo vedo un uccello migratore che guarda
dall'alto in basso un essere umano che
si è perso in campagna in montagna dice
guarda sto pirla io attraverso i
continenti orientandomi coi campi
elettromagnetici e questo non riesce
invece ad orientarsi in un fazzoletto di
terra grosso così sono intelligenze
diverse una volta la mia amica
intervistato margherita hack gli ha
detto dottoressa ma che mi dice
dell'intelligenza degli animali e lei fa
ognuno ha intelligenza che gli serve e
allora se questo il punto
cioè cooperare anche tra specie
differenti per creare un ambiente ancora
più rispettoso dei nostri bisogni che ci
facciano ritrovare il senso della nostra
esistenza
val la pena appunto di considerare la
cooperazione inter specie e gli animali
ce lo insegnano quindi io mi sono detto
perché no perché ho visto tante cose di
questo
a questo punto di vista perché no questa
è un'alleanza tra leoni perché no
perché no grazie